ah
what
hope everyone's doing okay it's um
it's a day isn't it
uh so let me see here
um have you ever owned a lego harry
potter set or
mini figures in your life no i was
well out of lego by the time harry
potter was a thing not that i was ever
that big into it anyways
are you familiar with the band oasis i'm
yes
i'm familiar with them not deeply
but yes
i'm assuming that's a lead-in to a
follow-up question
do you own a fez i do i don't yeah no oh
i've actually got two um what the
one that i use when i do the 11th doctor
is upstairs in my closet
and i've got this one
uh
let's see
uh i listened to the doctor who meets
lovecraft's story
i told you about best part was when a
mixed race pansexual non-binary
character told him how terrible he is
[Laughter]
okay i i may have to bump it up my list
of things to try and get to uh
what are your thoughts on hocus pocus
it's
fine it's i've gotta tip that
up just a little bit it i mean
i don't have the same level of nostalgia
for it a lot of people my age
do but it's fine
how's trixx also my sister's with me and
her favorite characters from buffy is
riley
put her down okay look i'm not gonna i
don't know your sister so i'm not gonna
say anything against her but
i am confused
like very confused i mean i'll grant you
he's a nice guy
who you can take home to meet your
parents but like
he's boring did you hear about the owl
house
that show shattered lgbtq glass ceiling
on
disney i had heard i haven't watched it
and i don't know the details of it but i
am aware that it's a thing
the follow-up question being do you
prefer british entertainment more than
american entertainment
i not
rely i don't reliably favor one over the
other i
like i i take in a fair amount of
british stuff but i don't consider
myself like an anglophile
or anything like that so
if you have disney plus have you seen
the howard ashman documentary i
do have disney plus i have not seen it i
hope too soon um are you buying the
blink house
no no i i don't quite have
that level of patreon funding yet are
you a fan of drag
not really but for reasons separate from
drag as an
art form i performed in drag
for a while before i discovered
burlesque so i have a lot of
personal baggage around drag
that you know it is it's the reason
i don't particularly enjoy actually i'll
let me back up
i like watching a drag king more than
drag queen
broadly speaking uh the nightmare before
christmas or corpse bride
depends on how musical i feel
um nightmare before christmas has much
better music corpse pride has a better
story
or at least it tells its story better i
think do you plan on doing any more dc
animation reviews or have you written
them off after
reign of the superman i haven't written
them off i just haven't gotten two of
them
just rewatched rocky a picture show with
my mom and all the songs just stuck in
my head those are good songs to have
stuck in your head she just hit me
you may have brought that one on
yourself you know
i started experiencing neil gaiman
sandman uh
i was not ready for 24 hours i
i have that as well like trying to find
time for this stuff is
is difficult i was recently on a drag
race
binge and your shirt had me quoting
bianca
del rio not today satan i did
four seasons of drag race after that
point i bailed because
the the backstage was getting a lot
cattier uh and it was reminding me too
much of why i stopped doing drag shows
so after the first four seasons i i i
bailed on that one
full metal jacket is getting a 4k
treatment this september
okay we get put into lockdown
i won't catch it i'll still go out
christopher eccleston is announced sorry
i can't leave the house i'm not risking
it
do you watch agents of shield i did the
first
two and a half seasons i
i can't remember if i finished season
three or not
i i bailed shortly after um
god i can't remember the characters
names anymore um
shortly after their really good
recurring villain was
turned into hive like you took a really
interesting character and made him
immensely generic and boring and now i
don't care
uh gets the link to your discord
nsfw chat looking back and forth meme
yeah yeah
uh 300 is getting a 4k treatment in
october i mean that's
that's all well and good i don't have a
4k tv
i don't really care i just i don't
my friend louisa will like this give us
your best
pick-up line i don't have the best
pick-up line
because i don't use pickup lines because
i'm too good for them no it's because i
don't have the confidence to try and
have a pickup line and i find them too
sleazy to even jokingly have a pickup
line
so i'm an utter disappointment
uh on that front is what i
am you did drag i need to find this on
the internet
there's videos of me doing drag and
burlesque on youtube if you feel like
hunting around a bit
are you saying showgirls was a
documentary i can't speak to that
because i've done drag i've done
burlesque i was never a stripper
and i've certainly never worked in vegas
so cannot speak to that
uh there's only one specific song for
marcus stuck in my head and i love it
but i also hate it well i suppose it
depends on the song
this is a whole big either or um
this time around sweeney taught her into
the woods sweeney todd
uh if you could make any episode of a dr
light episode that wasn't before which
one would you pick
oh that's easy crimson horror have you
seen the brave new world mini series i
have not
i don't even remember what it's on
uh are you the devil because you're hot
as hell
cheeky do you listen to big finish
who often not as often as i would like
to like with
most things that you know would
theoretically be done just for pleasure
i don't have the time right now i'm
really trying to knuckle down and get
the book move forward
have you ever watched crime action drama
shows uh like lost breaking bad sons of
anarchy prison break etc i watched the
first thing that i've lost
loved it heard so many divisive things
after that and kind of liked
the mystery i'm like i don't really care
about the answers i enjoyed that first
season and i left it at that
i watched breaking bad it's good um it's
a little over praise but it's good
i have not seen sons of anarchy have not
seen prison break
it's it's a dice roll whether i ever get
into that kind of stuff
uh last night watched a film from 2013
called enemy
it's the kind of film that really
requires a lot of complex analysis to
interpret
that's the uh denis villanue movie i'm
assuming i haven't seen that one i think
that's one of the few things he's
directed that i haven't seen yet
um you doing drag wow never had you down
as the racing type
did you ever watch heroes if so any
thoughts
uh no never watched it again that was
one that i missed the first season and
then everyone got mad at the second
season i'm like oh well i just won't
i'll just skip then looking forward to
your caretaker review for me it's a
microcosm of what i didn't like about
series eight so much time spent at cole
hill school i
don't think it works as a microcosm of
the problems with series 8 because
the problems with that episode are
actually don't extrapolate out
into the rest of the series i mean if
you want to say too much time at cole
hill that's about the one thing but
certainly the problems i have with the
caretaker because spoiler alert i don't
exactly praise the episode and the
in the review that's going to be coming
out um
my problems don't have to do with the
school setting it has to do with
approach and characterization and things
like that
and i'm not entirely sure that those are
um and if that serves as a microcosm at
least for the problems that i have
how to fix brother bear i'd have to
watch it first
uh have you seen hamilton on disney plus
not only have i seen it there's a review
of me and my partner liz up in the break
room so
go check that out when we're done
um so just a heads up with the questions
they are coming fast and furious that's
what i get for putting
q a in the title i am not promising
that i will catch everybody's questions
if you want to guarantee that i catch
your question you need to do it as a
super chat because these are
going fast and i might have to give up
trying to keep up with them
pretty soon uh i'm kind of happy to
report that the high school near me is
letting kids back
but also offering online and mass for
kids who don't have them
i i don't want to talk about schools
i just really don't i don't get the hate
for the fly episode of breaking bad it's
one of my favorite ones
uh it's not a favorite but it's fine
uh did you ever watch three's company
and which person was your favorite mine
was jack
i have seen a little bit of three's
company um
yeah jack was probably the most fun did
you watch the 80s and 90s beauty and b
show oh the one with um ron pearlman
um and linda hamilton
no no i've seen clips
can you tell us how can you tell if
someone's taking anabolic steroids i
have no idea
ask a doctor say would you like about
the first season of
umbrella academy but the fight scene in
the in the donut shop was great
the show in general has a good fight
scenes but like it takes a lot for an
action beat to be what sells me
especially on a tv show
do you do yoga nope
how soon do you think we will see jack
again midway through series
13 i expect no question just something
with love from scarlet oh thank you
amanda
uh i've just about sold my
first after lockdown event so sharing
the good vibes oh
thank you very much are you doing
personally emotionally you're good
i'm i'm doing okay
yeah the school thing's probably my own
baggage was in high school when i saw it
i'm going to guess the problems you have
are related to the doctor's issues with
soldiers that's not the only problem i
have but
uh it's going to come up
have you ever cried at frankfurter's
death i always do
no be
because he's too deplorable a human well
not human alien
but too much of what happens to him is
brought on by him
by him and he's just
too awful person and like i love frank
don't get me wrong frank is an amazing
character
but like frank's a terrible person like
really
uh i'm the person's sister who just hit
him
my favorite character is spike not
really riley oh
then you were absolutely correct to hit
him
yes he deserved that
have you ever seen the film long kiss
good night i have not in a
long dang time but yeah oh
god tracy thank you
what if any non-fiction genres do you
enjoy i don't
read nonfiction with any particular
reliability
about as close as i come is usually
autobiographical things and then i'll
usually do audio book
um like i like autobiographical
works with a comedic tone to them so
like
i've listened to louis black's book on
audiobook i listened to trevor noah's
autobiography on audiobook and you know
these things aren't necessarily comedic
start to finish but they they're come
out from a comedic angle
and that tends to be what i enjoy uh
when it comes to nonfiction
i think maybe just because the real
world is so often not
fun and funny i would prefer someone
with a view that
will make me laugh about it yoga is just
stretching for pretentious people
knowing some people who are super good
at yoga i'm
gonna disagree with you on that rocky
horror picture show a little shot before
rocky horror my mother is in love with
the popular sitcom on netflix called
frank
it's grace and frankie not frankie grace
we should tell you that yes i'm aware of
it
well not a bad show i'm a little
skeptical as to how it tackles series
topics what about you
i've only seen about half of the first
season it seemed to be doing it pretty
well but i know there's a lot more
season than that
liz likes it uh my partner
is the 13th doctor still a hufflepuff
after watching series 12.
somebody it might have even been you
jamie somebody asked that in a comment
today and i didn't
reply to it um partly because i don't
want to think about hogwarts houses
right now um just
just kind of don't
so forgive me for uh for passing on that
have you seen the stranger on netflix no
i actually have not even heard of that
usually when long lost siblings are
introduced in tv shows and movies things
fall apart
specter sherlock fantastic bees have you
ever seen this trope done well i have
one example i would love to hear your
one example
cause off the top my head no
loki's a terrible person too and i cried
at his death
i didn't sorry
he is a horrible person but it still
makes me sad somehow no that's
fair enough i didn't say it it's not a
reason that other people shouldn't cry
it's just the reason i don't
but everyone likes spike yes
yes they do um
[Music]
seeing as your reviews are coming up
i'll just say i actually don't mind
courtney as a character i love her
coming on the tardis with
the cleaning stuff and the wrist
bracelets i'll but you'll you'll get to
see my thoughts on her
for me the caretaker fits a bit feels a
bit to sarah jane adventures
one monster that can destroy the
universe defeated by a backflip
and some jiggery pokery yeah i mean
that's the trappings and the problems
with that run a bit deeper
than that what's your favorite pixar
movie um
at this point i don't know it was up for
a while but
i still like up um
inside out maybe
i find pixar really overrated at this
point
not bad just overrated
uh i released the third episode of my
audio series some people say it is too
dark they ain't seen nothing yet oh dear
uh i'm so sorry i didn't mean to bring
that up it's okay
i know i know you didn't mean to i
thought that keeps me up at night is
that it must
is what it must have felt like for all
those who were affected when thanos
snapped his fingers
hmm uh
discord yes i have this i generally
checked the discord at
45 minutes in knives out sequel
good good or bad idea
i deal with potential the only reason
i'm cautious about it is because
so much of what was great about that
movie was not just
the detective character played by daniel
craig
and really he's the only character who
you could transplant to a new story
and while he's great like he's hardly
the only good thing about it so i do
worry
about being able to find a
um you know a cast and a scenario that
is going to bring
as much out of it as as that one did
out for a walk
[ __ ]
uh let's see here team captain america
or team iron man
depends are we talking about the comics
or the movies because
the movie
if i was actually there and didn't have
like the omnipotent
uh audience view that we actually get
probably team iron man
and the comics neither i'd hide in a
bunker because they were both
morons have you watched season three of
westworld i
did they and there are reviews up but
they're not on this channel they're in
the break room of geeks
because my westworld videos didn't do
particularly well so i
shifted those over there i was not a
huge
um fan of season three unfortunately
favorite danny boyle movie
oh that one's tough feel like he's
gotten an odd kind of backlash
i still actually really like um slumdog
millionaire
sorry
uh talking about disney thoughts on
disney plus asking 30 bucks for mulan
well it's
that's a standard amount for something
dave for something that is of size
debuting
on a platform like that that's not that
far off from what
uh trolls world tour ran so anyone
complaining about the price i'm like
well no that that's a totally viable
price
and it makes sense um because you know
especially if if they're doing this
instead of a theatrical for all intents
and purposes
that's actually a good deal for
something like that that's a family film
because if you've got a kid odds are 30
bucks is what it would cost most parents
to take their kids to the movies that's
before even talking about snacks if
they've got two kids
they're already ahead paying 30 bucks to
see the movie
i do have some thoughts on on the
possible ripple effects and how that
might impact the overall industry but
i'm
that's i'm gonna get to that at another
time i've seen the marvelous
uh mrs maisel of amazon prime i have not
largely because um liz tried watching it
she
hates it she cannot stand that show and
her describing it to me kind of put me
off it a little bit how to fix parts of
the caribbean
uh at world's end you don't have to
there's nothing wrong with that world's
end
that is an overhated movie
i love your water flask thank you this
actually just came in today
and if you go to my teespring store
i have i have merch
of this not that you would actually get
this but it it
it's on shirts and stuff and it says
it's just it has an image of this
water honest so
not only do i have this i have merch to
associate with it
because build your brand that's part of
trying to have this be my job which i
suppose
it was the thing that i had kind of
intended to mostly focus on but the q a
is all over the dang place so maybe i'll
i'll i'll sort of
now that we're about a third of the way
in
sort of pause and and talk about this um
so i am making an effort
to see if i can get
things to where this
is my job now where i'm at right now
in terms of the patreon support and what
i usually get per month
off of youtube it is actually
covering my current bills
barely like skin of the teeth so first
problem there is i
i'm lacking i'm not i don't have the
ability to build a safety net so that's
the first problem
but in addition to that it's only
current covering my current
uh expenses when we get to the end of
the year and i have to
cover my taxes on things like the house
and the income from things like patreon
that what i'm making right now doesn't
doesn't give me enough to cover my bills
and afford to do that so
i am really focusing these next few
months on trying to
build what i have um and get
more streams of revenue in
and i
i i do have hope because i i had
expected
a bump when i announced that i was laid
off
but i didn't expect one as big as i got
and i also expected it to drop off the
month after
like it was just gonna be a temporary
thing but
it hasn't like there was a big initial
spike no question but
it hasn't now plateaued and dropped off
so i
might be able to pull this off it's
gonna be
i'm not like a complete spending freeze
right now for anything that is not
essential but
um might be able to pull this off
oh i feel really nervous putting that
out into the world
um how would you make a doctor who video
game oh i have no idea
i have no i have no business talking
video game design
the problem with doing a top 10 pixar
villains list would
be having to talk about hopper and his
voice actor
i mean it's it's anyone's personal
problem personal
thing whether or not they feel the need
to talk about that or how much
who's your favorite member of the
umbrella academy klaus
is there a soft drink that is no longer
around but you wish would make a
resurgence of
some kind no because i don't like soft
drinks any of them
never have have you played fallout new
vegas
nope uh we have echoes and back would
you want to see matt smith or peter
capaldi ever make a return in big finish
yes but i'm not as
gung-ho not that i wouldn't like them to
come back but like
i haven't missed them as much as i've
missed
uh christopher eccleston so you know
uh let's see
sorry where do i leave off um
sorry i lost the chat there for a second
please take care of yourself drink lots
of water get lots of rest
you're a joy to watch thousands don't
don't worry i've got plenty of water
hmm that's good water
do you watch south park nope used to
don't anymore
have you ever seen the film short bus
short bus by john cameron mitchell
probably one of the most enjoyable if
not best lgbtq films i've seen
but an nc 17. um so
i haven't seen it yet a couple of quick
things the first is
i'm probably due to try and watch hedwig
in the angry inch again i tried
a long time ago and got maybe
20 minutes into it i'm like i'm just not
feeling this now here's what's funny to
me about short bus
it was filming in new york while i was
living there
and i saw the posting for casting calls
for that and i almost i almost went to
try and audition to be in the thing
but no i haven't seen it yet
uh i don't know if it's allowed in
america but when i go to the cinema i
just get packets of sweets from
poundland and take them in with me um
it's well
strictly speaking it's not like a
national law but businesses are allowed
to set their own rules and pretty much
all um all
theaters in the u.s say don't bring in
outside food
doesn't mean people don't of course they
do but you're not supposed to
um because they make way more money off
the concessions than they do off the
movie tickets
would it be shilling if you were
sponsored by raycon for some of your
videos look i am not above shilling
but i'm not big enough for most of those
places um that said there will be a
sponsored
video later this month so like i do
still get sponsors every now and then
but you know it's sporadic and
it getting sponsors will be easier
if i can ever break a 100 000
subscribers
that's a ways off though i'd just be
happy to break 50 this year but i'm not
even sure that's
that's going on let's see the thing is
what i'm
trying to get it so this
is my source of income
you know this and my other creative
endeavors like the book and whatnot
i'm i'm moving forward based on the
assumption that
um my platform does not grow
substantially
because it might but i'm not i can't
build a financial plan off of
fingers crossed i hope i get to a
certain
milestone of size and regular you know
view size
in the future and be dependent on that i
i have to move forward using what i
currently get reliably per month
as my baseline and assuming that that's
what i'll get
what else can i do to move that forward
and so if that grows and i've made a
plan based on the assumption that it
doesn't
particularly much then i'm really in
good shape
we'll see to be honest i think all the
pirate sequels
are unnecessarily hated films i did not
like the fourth one very much i didn't
watch the fifth one
uh did you watch stu bagbull's interview
with rob sherman i started it but it's
long so i haven't finished it yet
uh sorry well i'm afraid louise and liz
are now mortal enemies because she loves
miss maisel
favorite musical episodes of non-musical
tv
i mean it's it is still hard to beat the
buffy musical episode
any fellow youtubers that you want to
work with um
quite a few actually a lot of the ones
that i'd really like to work with
i would not know how to get in touch
with
in any real way like most people have
like a contact me
thing but like that
that doesn't get you anywhere but like
i'd love to do
something with somebody like linkara
i think that would be uh a lot of fun
um especially given that 90s comics
which is a notoriously bad age was the
only time that i was regularly buying
issues of comic books um so like
something like that would be very fun
um jessie jender and i are talking about
doing a video collaboration and it's
funny that we haven't
because like she's contributed voice
work to some of my videos i've
unlike appeared to do parts that she
scripted
for some of her videos but we haven't
actually collaborated from top to bottom
um on a project yet but we're working on
that
do you watch the boys nope i do not
uh would you ever want to in uh
interview edgar wright if given the
chance
well sure i don't know
why he'd let me but sure i'm also quite
offended
there was my invite to the winery where
was the invite to the winery with you
and liz
uh the wineries that's a personal thing
how do you do big finish review uh
i i know you do big vintage review but
have you listened to any torchwood and
if so what do you think
i purchased aliens among us par one the
other day and listened to
it all in one it's fab i have not
listened to any of the torchwood
audios as yet you can do that thank you
lots of words of encouragement i do
absolutely appreciate those
um okay i'm losing the chat again
there we go i've been doing youtube on
and off for years
how do you stay motivated to produce
long form edited content i get bored way
too easily
um practice and at this moment in time i
don't have a lot else to do well i have
the book to edit but
procrastination uh
oh yeah i'd have thought jafar would
have been on your disney villains list
lots of people were shocked that he that
he that he wasn't included
and like always not putting him on my
best list does not mean i don't like
jafar i like jafar fine
but like i don't know maybe it's because
i grew up in the 90s in my mind he's
kind of standard
there isn't a lot about him that stands
out to me aside from his sidekick
now if i was ranking villain double acts
he and iago would make that list but by
himself
it is fine
aside from removing the questionably
transphobic character
how would you fix conair you don't have
to fix conair con air's supposed to be
stupid
the there's fixing it would actually
break it it's working as intended
which show made your rage quit i'm
i don't think i've ever rage quit a show
i've dropped off i've like i've had
times where i've gone
like okay i'm just gonna take a breather
and just never came back that's
basically what happened with
um agents of shield i don't remember
ever rage quitting a show
now uh still
uh loving my doctor who fob watching
necklace
do you like the elder scrolls series
i've only ever played a little bit of
skyrim
and it seemed fine but it's the kind of
thing that it i almost never
um
yeah i almost never sink the amount of
time into it that you need to fully
appreciate it
uh do you agree that lego batman the
video game is a masterpiece masterpiece
no
fun yes played that one with my kid
actually
uh which doctor do you think would be
most likely to start a youtube
channel ooh
probably 13.
have you heard of the musical dear evan
hansen yes but only because spotify
keeps trying to suggest me tracks from
it
almost every time i've gone to a theater
i brought in outside
food still have yet to get caught i mean
like they don't it's pretty rare that
they check
bags so like you have to be really
blatant to get caught
but even in that case most people end up
getting at least a soda or if you want
popcorn most people aren't going to
bring that in
um having seen short bus that would have
been interesting oh yes i i've heard
um do you watch arrow and other cw shows
and if so what did
uh what did you think of crisis i don't
watch arrow i watch
legends of tomorrow and crisis was
good except for the episodes that focus
on ollie because i don't
like this version of ollie especially so
crisis started well ended pretty well
there were a few episodes in the middle
where kind of disappeared up its own but
being all self-congratulatory and being
a big celebration of ollie and like i
get it
like his show started the thing but like
because i don't like him
i don't care sorry
uh do you know anywhere you can watch
classical episodes yes bret box
uh it is a subscription service not a
particularly expensive one
did you ever play that pirates of the
caribbean mmorpg from 2014
no i don't play mmorpgs i've never
played mmorpgs
i would i would lose track of my life
well you can always collab with me pitch
me an idea
who's your favorite member of the
umbrella academy klaus i said
uh james goss the manager of timelier
victoria said the bbc
told him they wanted to do the project
then handed it to him
i think it might tie into chippenhall's
five-year plan of the show i doubt it
i very seriously doubt it
i don't know why just intuition tells me
no
my intuition more often than not is that
things are
never going to um be tied together
as intricately as fans imagine they will
be
like i learned that from marvel with
people being like oh and they'll bring
in these things from
the asians of shield show or this thing
from the supporting
shorts that they did i'm like no they
won't and they didn't
what are your thoughts on glee don't
like it
that that is my thought i was curious to
watch some of joel schumacher's better
film since learning he passed away in
june didn't get into lost boys um
so much but shame uh not more know about
phone booth phone booth is a very good
movie
um i like lost boys i find lost boys to
be quite fun
falling down is another one uh if you
want a better version of joker
watch falling down that's right i said
it
uh you're gonna have to update the
channel logo and the credits
i i have but uh a lot of the
things coming out were edited prior to
my having done that update so you're
still gonna see
the outdated logo in a couple of videos
but i have already done that
uh the best disney villain is bethesda
they even have a song oh dear
my sister just came back in tell her to
stop nicking my vape
how would you both just stop vaping
sorry i don't get the appeal
have you ever had a mimosa oh yes oh yes
not too often these days though because
um liz created by accident
my preference to a mimosa
it is something that she has dubbed
berry nonsense
it is moscato
and um sort of like a
pink lemonade and hard cider
and champagne and i'm probably
forgetting something else that's in
there and and fresh berries
floating in the top and it's flipping
amazing
i know it's hard to get hold of but have
you ever read the human nature novel
no i have not what are your thoughts on
zoe's extraordinary playlist
it is a title i have heard before
that is my thought
uh did you like oh damn
i don't know why this thing keeps
jumping down to the bottom when i'm
trying to hold it up higher up did you
like how crisis
wrote off 90s flash yeah i thought that
was kind of sweet
it's fine and i wasn't a huge fan of
crisis either and the flash is my
favorite out of the arrowverse
i did two seasons of the flash and after
that i was so
annoyed with barry as a lead i'm just
like i can't anymore
just for clarification i assume you
don't like arrow the character but okay
with steve and amell
stephen amell's a guy he's
fine i don't like the characterization
of this version of ollie it's not about
performance it's about how he's written
he's a douche and he's a douche in the
comics too but that's why i like him
in things like justice league where he
shows up as a side character he's not
the kind of person i want to follow
you need an faq
uh yeah that might save me some time do
you watch the simpsons
not currently but i have in the past
how much proof is your water take a
guess
uh who would you cast for the doctor
next one male and female suggestion
please
i mean i did a whole video on people who
i would like to see play the doctor so
watch that after we're done here do you
feel like vinya was dark phoenix done
right
no i feel like dark phoenix was dark
phoenix done right but when i say that i
mean the comic book
um vania was dark phoenix done
better than either of the movie versions
we've seen
dark phoenix done but that doesn't mean
i like
vanya's arc in season one because i
actually don't
uh you should definitely check out this
other channel and subscribe it's
definitely
not my other channel where i put all my
professional work
what's your favorite cheese more
seriously thoughts on
uh kamala harris so generally sharp
cheddar like extra sharp cheddar
like cheddar so sharp it turns most
people off that's
that's my cheese of choice
uh kamala harris i think is a solid pick
um i mean we've known for a while that
biden was gonna pick a woman
um i didn't want warren not that i don't
like warren but i wanted somebody
younger than that uh to be the
supporting person on his ticket i think
i think she was a good fit
for him i think she'll do a lot to
counterbalance some of his
weaker areas um at least in terms of
appealing to
um you know the left to help ensure
that the the
democratic base actually comes out and
votes because
boy i don't mean to talk about politics
but i wasn't this was actually super
chat so i feel like i've been
financially empowered to talk politics
for a hot minute
when it was clear that biden was going
to get the nomination i had flashbacks
to
carrie challenging
george w bush at his second term
now george w bush was not popular
at that point and it should not have
been that hard
for the democrats to beat him
the thing is carrie was so milk toast
and so unengaging and so
boring unimpressive nobody could get
excited about carrie and i do think
that's a big part of why they lost
and i was getting that feel
off of biden being nominated
felt like the most boring middle of the
road possible choice
so i think having someone like kamala
harris on the ticket
will not do everything but do something
to alleviate that a little bit
we'll see uh black widow or agent peggy
carter
um black widow generally speaking
uh do you like bahama mamas i think i've
had a bahama mama
it's been a long time i don't remember
off the top of my head
uh do you think they'll use any
returning villains for the ninth
doctor's big finish adventure if so
which ones
um i doubt it
um largely because most of the
returning villains when they showed up
again in
new who they
it was treated as like the first time
having seen them in a long
long time um so
if they did they they'd have to pick
somebody
who isn't who hasn't been reintroduced
into new who so if they wanted to bring
back
i don't know the draconians or heck
bring back omega big finish has worked
with omega a couple of times
so they could bring him um
but i i would not i would not expect him
to
he can't run into the daleks because he
thinks that alex are dead when he
sees one in series one um
i suppose cybermen are possible
i guess there was a real reason it
couldn't be the cybermen
i wouldn't i definitely wouldn't want
them to overload it with returning
villains though uh
that very nonsense drink sounds good i
love a mimosa too it's good stuff
have you ever been to wales home of a
home to all of new who i have not
i've been to london that is the extent
of my visit to england i had my
honeymoon there
for a week i remember seeing scott
and ramona should not have stayed
together in scott pilgrim versus the
world
uh there was actually a film to
alternate ending where they didn't
and they shouldn't have that's not to
say they should never have gotten
together
but at that point their lives no no they
absolutely shouldn't have
they needed to they needed to both learn
how to be single and deal with their
freaking damage the actor who plays
cosplay is a similar character on a show
called misfits it's also a dark yet
ridiculous
superhero show only it was young adults
on community service
i did hear about that i know it's a
couple years old but what did you think
of the
bat batgirl bat man scene in the killing
joke
this is what i thought of that
tangled or frozen i prefer frozen silly
question but do you prefer your water
hot or cold
room temperature uh
i just got home from a bike ride sorry
i'm late no worries
um my first live stream oh god they
answer my question
i'm so happy i could cry another year
later
oh hey nathaniel yeah see it's nice to
have regulars
uh oh hey jesse didn't see you pop in
you know if you had a bahama mama
let's see biden wasn't my first pick but
i'm going to vote for him happily
yeah yeah
uh forgetting the time period and while
i definitely don't agree
with what he did uh
i kind of understand where the husband
in umbrella academy season two was so
annoyed
like i guess but also
tell with that guy ecclesson could meet
the centaurus i guess yeah i suppose so
no real reason why not oh time to check
the discord thank you
carowind so and this is your regular
reminder that the discord is a patreon
exclusive perk so if you would like
access to the discord then
you can pop on over to the patreon i
would say that asking questions gets a
guaranteed answer except i try and keep
up with that anyway i should get worse
i should get worse at keeping up with
the questions on the chat so that would
incentivize people to get on the discord
so that their questions would actually
get answered except i would feel like an
ass if i did that
see that this is part of why i'm not
doing better
at youtubing
uh does the holding photo
mean there's special water at play this
evening well
yes uh i hope this question isn't too
much of a downer but it's been on my
mind oh boy
i'd like to revisit universal studios in
future as i want to go on the rides
but i think i feel guilty about it
knowing
part of the price of the ticket would go
towards the harry potter sections
of whichever park i'm visiting i was
visiting even if i don't visit those
themed areas in person what do you think
that there are certain things
that it's one thing removed
so like the harry potter portions of
universal studios aren't a separate
thing
it's part of the whole same deal so
you can't really take in one without
doing the other and in the case of
something like that
um whether or not they're going to
continue to maintain
that licensing deal is going to be
determined by
the foot traffic in that section and
they've already paid
whatever they're paying for how many
years of licensing that they've got on
it
so if you buy a ticket to universal
studios and don't go to that portion of
the park
you're not really contributing like
technically you are because
your ticket goes to the business that
did the licensing deal and so forth
but whether or not they continue to
maintain that part of the park is going
to depend on the foot traffic in that
specific part of the park
so if you're not contributing to that i
would say you're fine
totally water in that flask oh wouldn't
you like to know
uh when and how did you start to raise
income from youtube i kind of assumed
you started
uh just uploading for fun etc um i did
start uploading for fun um but i mean
i i also started uploading long enough
ago that it was before
all the milestones that you had to hit
before you could be monetized so i was
monetized from the very beginning
um i had no hope of
having this be my job until fairly
recently
um but like i've been getting paid
from youtube since
about a year into it and the only reason
i say that is like again i didn't have
to hit milestones to start getting paid
but
the way youtube monetization works is if
you have not generated at least 100
in revenue then they pull that money
roll it over to the next month until
you've accumulated enough
to um to
cumulatively be a hundred dollars
because that's the minimum payout that
they'll
do so it took me about a year year and a
half maybe before i got paid for the
first time
uh the husband and umbrella academy you
mean allison's husband what
what's wrong with him no we were talking
about um
carl i think was his name no you
you were thinking about the wrong
husband little sister uh what's your
opinion on the watchmen show my opinion
is i need to see it
uh was there anybody that you wanted to
be the democratic nominee
um i wasn't
all in on anyone but i did like kamala
harris better than biden i liked cory
booker
um i do i do like bernie but i'm also
from vermont so that's
almost kind of a given um
i i'll tell you what though i i hope we
never see mayor pete again
like ever i don't want him to i don't
want him to run for dog catcher
he can go away forever
oh yeah to hell with carl yeah see there
you go we're on the same page now
um hold on folks somebody's typing into
questions of the discord as i'm here
and after that i will pop on back over
see how long this takes to get typed
don't worry i'm not going to say your
name who you are but you know
it's either a long question or a or the
thing's
slow to put it through
and now it doesn't say you're typing
anymore
[Music]
i'm um head back i think oh wait typing
again okay
i'm gonna i think you scared them away i
didn't mean to
i didn't i didn't mean to to tease and
scare anybody away
sorry i was trying to stall i was trying
to stall for time was all that i was
trying to do oh heck i can't believe i
didn't think of this earlier oh
hey pup oh god now they're
okay they're both typing now uh been
typing in the live chat like a peasant
yes see
you had access to something finer uh
every live stream i'm gonna recommend
the comic series deceased
uh isn't it just the dc equivalent of
marvel zombies though
okay i'm popping on back to the chat um
do you want a new tardis team
for uh nine or do you want rose and jack
for me i prefer the latter
what i would like them to do i would
like to have the first box set
be the ninth doctor before encountering
rose and then
later box sets to have rose and then
rose and jack
i'd like them to jump between times
there
just finished watching life on mars with
john sim and loved it have you seen it i
have not
um
where did i leave off
uh what modern slang what has caught you
the most off guard either
in meeting context or actual words
um like that kind of thing does throw me
off depending on where it shows up but
i'm having a hard time
thinking of the best example
how to fix never ending story two and
three
i've only seen two i do know three
exists though it's got jack black in it
i'm trying to make youtube videos what
kind of mic are you using sorry blane
question i guess
um at present i have a blue yeti
uh which i actually need to replace
because the cord got caught in the
vacuum cleaner
um but
that's that's what i had been using
recently prior to that i had a i had a
road
a vid mic well i still have a rode vid
mic
which is good but it's a pain in my butt
because it's got an auto gain
that i can't turn off so that's a pain
in the butt have you seen ghost like i
have but i have not rewatched it in a
while i remember just being
confused by it
uh what was the factor that made you
dislike glee
just the vibe and also i think the fact
that i found out that there was an
episode called an
asian f about an asian character
getting something other than an a i
think the minute i read that i was like
oh god
no just no who would have been a good
choice for the master for the ninth
doctor
oh that is a good question
and that's the kind of question i would
have to think about
so i don't know
uh you've only been to london you need
to come down to yorkshire
you think you like a drink
yes i've heard that
let's see oh i'm almost caught up on
questions
yay
uh you say blue yeti i think the drink
tumblers
have you read the witcher books or seen
the show or played the game no
no no i just got season 14 on blu-ray
earlier this week
oh nice was there ever a webcomic you
were into which
yes i was into and i actually would like
to get back into
sluggy freelance
uh i'm hoping somebody in the chat
recognizes this
and knows who this is i doubt it
but sluggy freelance was very much my
jam
for a long time ah now i'm knocking over
stuff trying to put it back
ah dang thing get
back and you go no ah
gotta have to fix that later uh
what's your favorite food homemade
macaroni and cheese
eddie izzard for ecclestone's master he
would have worked
um my current favorite doctor pair would
be
eight and thirteen i think they would
work so well that would be interesting
to see
you should do a video of masters for
doctors that never had masters
i i feel like that that might be too
deep a cut
i mean maybe i'd think about it
favorite weird owl song probably yoda
uh you can only choose one what did i
miss or you'll be back oh you'll be back
oh where did oh god everything got
knocked down
you'll be back wait and see
sorry this is bugging me because it's in
the corner of my eye so i'm trying to
put this back and i cannot sing
any more of that song even in jest
because i've lost uh monetization on
these things before because of
singing a song that i don't have the
rights to
all right deceased is somewhat compared
to marvel zombies but it doesn't get as
ridiculous
deals greatly with superman and comes up
with interesting ways characters would
use
their power i mean the part of the thing
is i'm not
as into dc as i am marvel anyway so
if it depends on prior knowledge of the
characters i might be in the dark
anyways
some people cuddle teddy's at night i
have a statue of the groom read bro
watching me while i sleep oh
that's sweet which doctor do you think
is the best singer my money's on pertwee
um
i don't know i feel like tendon could
probably carry a tune
how much you want to bet i'm wrong about
that though
uh have you any history with writing
fanfic
uh with what with what if so no
i've never written fanfic
see unpopular opinion i did not hate
jared leto's joker that is an unpopular
opinion to be honest i'm a little
annoyed that the 11th doctor never
encountered the master in the show
i'm sure he would have stayed for more
than a series but i
i do i do think davey's made a very good
call
only in only uh introducing
one um major
past villain per series so series one we
got the daleks there's two of the
cybermen
series three was the master series four
was when we got the centaurons back so i
like that he spaced those out because if
ecclestone had never encountered the
master that means we would have had the
daleks and the master in the same
13 episode series i think that would
have been overcrowding
uh not to mention uh when you do that
video big finish we'll have a master
cast for each of those doctors
yeah that's also possibly true
what would you want out of uh what would
you
want the next out of time cds to be so
which doctor pairing
which monsters should these doctors face
i don't know i haven't thought about
that one
speaking of glee did you hear about leia
michelle no what'd she do now
i think nine shouldn't have had the
master because he still needs to think
the time lords are dead
yes there's that too um
let's see where was i okay is that
disney some some
no that was not a sum sum-sum that was
that
was bun bun is what that was
creamy mac and cheese are baked baked
uh are you into anime a little
not deeply what are your thoughts on
suicide squad now that's the movie
that's on my list to consider for
how to fix
uh you know what's really depressing
this channel the one i'm using now has
more subscribers than the one i put
genuine effort into
that is not uncommon like
none of the videos i put the most time
and work into are my most viewed videos
i i can name you three videos that i put
back breaking amounts of time into
the video that i did on cowboy bebop the
video i did on lego movie 2
the video i did on ghostbusters 2.
those were by far my heaviest workloads
in terms of
in terms of planning editing the the
works
low views all three of them
uh if you could would you have matt
stayed for series eight and have capaldi
be series nine through 11 personally i
would
um i guess i'm not sure in my head what
the benefit would have been for that
frozen or moana moana i do like moana
better than frozen
i predict the final episode channel
rights will have the return
of the sex cloud from day one
oh god would be the regeneration the
doctor would look back on most fondly oh
god that i hate day one so much
that almost made me rage quit a show
you should hear tennis rendition of
sunshine uh
on leith from children in need
uh does it seem reasonable
to make a treatise on how any given work
is merely disappointing
and then uh dedicate
over 140p to it
even if the opinion is warranted is that
overkill i'm not
i'm not sure i'm totally following your
question oh i oh
is this is this about um
h bomber guy's thing on ruby that you're
talking about
is it overkill i mean maybe but if
that's
how much if that's how many thoughts you
have on the thing
and that's how long it takes you to
explore all those thoughts fully then
you know it is however long it is
uh which movie are you most looking
forward to watching tenet or dune
i am more curious about doom than i am
tenet but i want to see both
probably the most awkward question
you'll get yeah right
uh twilight or 50 shades of grey
it depends on whether you are asking
about genuine quality
or camp value because 50 shades of grey
is a goddamn riot if you do not think
about it for more than a second
because if you do then it is horrifying
now what 9th doctor stories do you want
in his big finish i have no i'm i'm not
a good person asked
to do speculation i want to see
is my answer or here rather um
i heard a rumor oh did you now
uh the benefit would be 11 got to face
the master missy and i think they would
play well off each other
i don't know missy seems so perfect for
for capaldi for me anyways
i heard a rumor that you subscribed to
me oh
i saw where you were going
any upcoming classical reviews yes um it
was voted on by the patreon
plug that again uh by the patreon
supporters that i'm going to be
um looking at the greatest show in the
galaxy this month and that
review will go up in the break room
let's see
uh favorite big finish companion
um big finish exclusive so no furbisher
uh evelyn smythe gremlins 2 is an
underrated masterpiece
yes yes
yes it is oh that movie's so fun
i love it that's my trash
what's your piano hitchhiker's got oh
dang it there it goes
uh what's your opinion on his anchor's
guide to the galaxy tv show from the 80s
i'm considering watching it
it's super dated visually um
other than that it's fine personally
couldn't get into ruby i never even
tried getting into ruby
what is your favorite new who episode
featuring unit um
probably the santaran two-parter
what's your favorite christopher nolan
film the prestige
uh the big moment in little mermaid that
you always cry at
was a last minute edition well then
thank goodness for last minute
auditions auditions additions i can talk
ah let's hydrate
i hope the ruth doctor isn't a preharmal
doctor who's actually the 14th doctor
and retcon
timeless child as that was an awful
addition to the lower thoughts i don't
want them to wreck on the timeless child
let chippenhall do whatever the hell it
is he's gonna do with it
and then i don't want it ever addressed
ever again
once chibnall does whatever it is he's
planning to do with that idea
we'll see it play out but then leave it
alone
i don't want to retcon i just want
future show runners to ignore it just
don't talk about it
that is that is my preferred way to deal
with
bad plot turns very rarely do i feel
that a retcon is actually necessary
i feel you're usually better just moving
forward and ignoring it
because the minute you start retconing
it then you make it the focus of what
you're doing again
you're bringing the bad thing up again
even if you're trying to fix it i'm not
going to say no retcons have ever worked
in the history of
long-form storytelling but generally i
i'm
not in favor of them and not because
like i'm thinking
you can't change the character not like
that but just like
i i feel like they're a waste of time
more often than not
um i do that said i would like joe
martin to
just be the next doctor i would just
like that
whether it turns out we met a prehearned
one or not fine have her cycle back and
use that face again
i would like her to be the next doctor
regardless at least twilight have
michael she and aka the only great thing
about those movies
i would argue the entire climax of
um breaking down part two is amazing
like in the stupidest way but it's
incredible
uh
yeah i've seen the film oh dang it
i've lost track of the dan i've seen the
film theory video on 50 shades of grey
yikes
i haven't seen film theories video i
have however
seen folding ideas three videos on them
i've seen
dominic noble's nine videos on them
um yeah yeah
do you consider yourself to be part of
bread tube you might have been asked
this before i don't know
i i don't think i am just because
my the videos that i make that are
that would fit under that heading like
my lgbtq
stuff are such a relatively small
percentage of what i do
like i do those videos i go out of my
way to do those videos once a month
and i'll talk about them more often if
something comes up and i'm in that
mindset certainly but i feel like
what i do that might not be enough of a
focus of what i do then again i don't
know i don't know what qualifies you as
a bread tuber
also like my perception of that question
is thrown off because all the bread tube
people that
i follow are all huge by my standards
like lindsay ellis and philosophy tube
and contra points
and h bomber guy and and they're all
they're
massive so like even thinking of myself
in that context makes me go
no no i can't be
um and so i guess that's why i feel
i feel comfortable being called a who
tuber because
like that i'm i'm more in keeping
subscriber-wise with with the size of
that community
what are your thoughts on pocahontas i
haven't seen it all the way through
still
uh a good anime to start is
uh haikyuu it's on netflix
i don't really need a starter i have
seen some animes i just
haven't gotten into that many do you
like any web comics not currently
great is showing the galaxy depressed me
it's good but i don't want to re-watch
it
well we'll see what i think of it have
you seen the second doctor story of the
mind robber i have
it's been a long time though i need to
rewatch that one
oh boy greatest show in the galaxy's
probably next to sue tech my favorite
one-off villain ooh
do you think big finish should publish
novelizations of audios
for deaf hard of hearing people ooh i
never thought of that
um broadly speaking philosophically
yes whether or not that works with their
business model i don't know because they
themselves are not a
publisher so they would have to partner
with
somebody else and they would risk
cutting into their own
revenue stream because it would not only
be
excuse me hard of hearing or deaf people
who would bought those there would be
some people who would
prefer those over the audio and because
they would have to split
that revenue with whoever they get to
actually print and publish the darn
things
that means they will be getting less per
sale for anyone who
made the personal choice to jump from
the audio to
the novels so i don't expect them to
ever do that
but philosophically that's a sound idea
have you read the graphic novel v for
vendetta if so what did you think of it
i have it's been a long time though
so i remember liking it but it's been a
while one of the guys who've always said
character on my audio series sent me a
massive hate message because i let the
bad guys win
ouch when your own cast rebels that's uh
that's something
um
hmm junk junk
drunk review on twilight and fifty
shades movies
somebody wants to pay me to do it i will
i watched arachnids in the uk again
today and i really enjoyed it
okay it's funny and everyone had good
character beats
why don't people like it also i enjoyed
over from 55.
uh orphan 55 i honestly think it's just
a structural
mess um
and then for iraqis in the uk my big
problem was chris
knowlth's character i hated that
character absolutely despised him
uh what's better the spider-man clone
saga or the timeless child
so the execution of the concept the
timeless child is better the core idea
the clone saga is better what disney
villain would you most like to see in
another disney villains
roll seriously or as a joke um
huh
oh that's such an
odd question i'm having trouble making
heads or tails of it um
i guess you know what might be
fun would be to see um
somebody like hades taking on the role
of jafar
uh where are we at the doctor in
distress video oh god yeah i still need
to do that
if you have to think about it you're not
a bread tuber is that the criteria
really uh i mean i know like on the
bread tube reddit they've linked to my
videos a couple times
they've been ignored when that's
happened but you know whatever
ah i really want to get into the earth
sea books after
dominic noble's video on le guin i've
read one of them i've read tombs of
aton i read that in college so again
long time ago
pizza hut dominos or papa john's ah
domino's by default uh the guy who um
well
i don't know if he still owns it but the
guy who who started papa john's is a
raging [ __ ] and pizza hut um does
not agree with me at all it's too dang
gracie
i live in america but my high school
principal has a british accent and just
from hearing two voicemails from him
i was able to place his accent as
manchester just like eccleston
nice uh if the greatest showman was
gonna be a show on broadway would you go
see it
i don't know
probably not i'm not a huge fan of
broadway adaptations of films honestly
and i've seen one of the better ones
i've seen spam a lot and i liked it well
enough but it wasn't amazing
we can get you to bread tube level if
you do the doctor in distress video
oh boy you people want me to suffer
uh do or have you watched modern family
if so thoughts i used to watch modern
family
i don't anymore i didn't make a decision
to stop watching i just didn't get
i just didn't keep up with it um and i
liked it it was nice it was a sweet show
number one missing story from doctor who
that you want to see restored
um 10th planet
which wedding would be more awkward
luther and allison
or number five in dolores luther and
allison
i honestly think would still be more
awkward could they include the textual
copy of the big finish audios on the cds
maybe but then that's going to up their
production cost
so it's going to jack up the prices of
the physical media which is already
significantly more expensive than the um
than the digital version anyway i need
to wrap this up soon
uh tim shaw is the timeless child
i wish drunk review of the rumor troll
2. uh
i don't know about that
but the problem is i'm generally i
generally don't go for
so bad it's good like for me it's just
so bad it's bad
i don't get why the comics try to do
photorealistic drawings instead of doing
drawings in the essence of them i agree
i hate photo referenced art
god drives me nuts white european is the
most underrated doctor who
episode of modern who um
most underrated for
my tastes i might give it to
robot of sherwood i also don't know
where the overall opinion stands right
now and can you hear me
i know it was very divided when that
episode aired i don't know if it settled
one direction or the other so depending
on where popular opinion finally landed
on
that i might that i might say that one
i do need to wrap up soon uh what person
and doctor who
do you wish was a companion for me big
finish i wish they made di patricia
menzies a six doctor companion and knew
who rita from the god complex rita would
have been good honestly um
uh perkins the uh
the engineer from mommy on the orient
express
he would have been a great companion
i've just started a rewatch of trial of
the time lord thinking of
threatening a commission actually better
than sixth first season
ah still unseen trial of a time lord
i was watching a youtube called
nightwing one and he was saying about dc
comic layoffs are you worried that a
chunk of characters
may stop getting comics made for them i
don't have as much of a stake
like personally emotionally in dc
um good grief um as i do with marvel
so like that happens anyway dc's
notorious for canceling
books even ones that are doing perfectly
fine
so
i don't know it's it's just kind of a
it's kind of the way the business is
uh i was able to be in spamalot freshman
year of high school
black knight and tim the enchanter my
two faves nice
there are those who call me tim
ah see film adaptations of broadway
shows into the woods
there's two hours of my life i'm never
getting back into the woods the film
version is one of my go-to examples of
failing to properly tailor something to
its new medium
uh remember you don't have to watch it
you have to sing it double money list
joins in
[Music]
the secret of an american tale lamb
before time or
or or all
dogs go to heaven the secret of nem
would be my preference out of those
choices
would luther and allison's wedding be as
awkward as barry and iris's wedding was
they're also foster siblings i don't
know i didn't see how that uh
wedding went probably on par drunk for
review of bird democ
favorite john hughes movie breakfast
club only one that's aged well
um well now planes trains and
automobiles hasn't aged horribly
but most john hughes has not aged well
most over
hated episode of knew who um
i don't know most of the ones that are
hated are hated with a decent reason
honestly off the top of my head
doctoring the widow in the wardrobe it's
not great but it's not awful
and i like madge i have a ranked list of
every doctor who episode i made it a few
years ago
and update it regularly am i crazy i did
the same for torchwood
i mean it's something some people do
it's not something i do
but two videos i'm still waiting for
gallivant review
working on it uh big finish audio
the marrying conspiracy i could have
sworn
that i did the marrying conspiracy okay
like you've got me paranoid now give me
a second
give me a second on that yeah i did the
marion conspiracy
march 17 2019 i did that one
don't do that to me don't mess with me
when i've been drinking
water
but yes the gallivant review that's
hopefully maybe next month more likely
the month after that one's going to be a
big
haul at a job saw spam on the uk
and you wouldn't you won't succeed on
broadway song doesn't work as they
changed it
to be about generic celebrities i don't
remember that song specifically would
you rather have from sure establish in
the show or a mega return
omega just because i would hate to see
a certain stripe of doctor who fandom go
oh this is so stupid when frobisher
shows up
uh would you want to see maisie williams
the shoulder me come back
if so with clara or on her own if she
ever comes back i do not want it to be
with clara i don't really want her to
come back
at this point uh did you read dark
knight's medal
nope a weird question but
how dark were your kids shows cause we
had a show where kids were trapped in a
tower forever and it was amazing um
kid the sorts of shows i watched as a
kid
were only dark if you stopped and
thought about it
like the real ghostbusters is kind of
dark but only if you stop and think
about it like the fact that these are
dead people
that that they're uh capturing
uh have you seen the swarm with michael
caine nope
drunken rant review of ferris bueller's
day off oh god
you would have to pay me to watch that
movie again i
oh i would have to bleep so much
of a review video for ferris bueller's
day off god
i hate it
uh which time or would you like to see
come back in the new series none
none leave it at one it worked well at
one
leave it alone thank you
watching joe west's speech as he tried
desperately to not mention that he was
both the bride and the groom's dad was
rather painful
oh do you like classic rock some of it
i have an excel spreadsheet for all my
doctor who reviews
not fair uh you did indeed review the
marriage conspiracy
thank you uh
you're funny when you're drunk i'm not
drunk i'm
hydrated
would you be uh on board for a big
finish set of luke running clyde from
sarah jane adventures
i'd support them making it i wouldn't
personally buy it
the raspy beer is back uh it's what i
get frustrated isn't it
i get the ah i get the gravel and the
voice
how much for ferris bueller interested
now i
i wouldn't charge you more i would
charge you the standard
60 bucks because it's just the one movie
out of
spite i would like to charge more but
i'm not going to be that bitter
i'm guessing at this point you're
probably wrapping up hopefully this
wonderful thing you do become your job
soon
the most inspiring word of all my cavity
very nice uh do you like segun
ekinola i love murray gold so much but i
can always not bad i've got i've gotten
used to
the new music drunk review of 16 candles
i've actually never seen
16 candles so that would be uh that
would be a fresh perspective
if you were commissioned for review
where you'd likely do a lot of swearing
would it be twice the price given the
extra work that involved
ooh i should i should make it that no i
wouldn't though
ah come on you couldn't get spiteful at
me i can
trying not to but again sorry for making
you worry i genuinely didn't get the
notification and didn't see it when i
checked
uh favorite tardis team
um
i go back and forth between 10 and donna
and seven and ace and i do need to wrap
it up because i've actually caught up on
the questions
uh what if there's an episode where 13
turns into a werewolf
what does she get bitten by queen
victoria
um okay
uh sorry i'm like oh thomas you're just
in time for me to finish
uh where does bill rank in terms of your
companions i have a companion ranking it
doesn't have the current companions on
it but bill's on there she's high
i like her quite a bit so
thank you everybody for tuning in thank
you for those who
did super chat thank you for those who
ask questions thank you for those who
just
sat back and listened to me ramble
thank you for all of you because i mean
right now this is my job by default
because this is what i'm doing but
we've got a shot at this
being what i do and that is
amazing if we can get there
fingers crossed we will see
but thanks all the same and please
remember that
you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved you are the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time
this council is my cavity